the peacekeeping force in Lebanon has
warned that the escalation in
hostilities along Israel's northern
border could widen Sarah hit has more
from the Israeli Lebanon
border well we've come to Israel's
northern border with Lebanon where an
estimated
65,000 Israelis received an order from
the government to leave their homes and
that's because of the barriage of
rockets coming from Hezbollah across the
border in Lebanon in the last few
minutes we heard outgoing artillery fire
from Israel into Lebanon and all along
this border there are plenty of
checkpoints to ensure that no one enters
what has now become a military zone but
we're going to go and have a look at
some of those evacuated
towns we got get out
[Music]
yeah okay we've just heard some sirens
and some Rockets there coming over from
Lebanon you can see on the hill there
and at the top that was a mortar that
you just saw that area you'll see is
blackened where it's been torched by
previous attacks there and that just
gives you a sense of what an easy target
this place
is this is the town of schom home to
8,000 residents but as you can see it's
a ghost town incredibly derel no one's
in the playgrounds the cars are here but
the schools are closed and so are the
shops and the windows shuttered on
either side just down this road here
there's also concern that many of the
businesses will go bankrupt with a lot
of Farmland here there's no one to pick
the produce all of this is Israel's
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu warns
that if Hezbollah wants an allout War
Beirut will become come another
Gaza I just want to give you an idea
where schlom is it's right next to that
border that separates Israel from
Lebanon which runs along the top of that
hill and in the last couple of years
Israel has fortified its border along
the north by reinforcing those walls
building more watchtowers and
surveillance as well not just to protect
these border towns but also to protect
its troops and while residents here say
that they're used to hasbalah Rockets
what they're not used to is the idea and
fear of being infiltrated the same way
those Southern towns were infiltrated on
October the 7th and that's what worries
them about coming back
home alaz schi